salut tout le monde donc cette semaine
vous l'avez compris je ne vais pas vous
parler de jeux vidéo je vais vous parler
d'un autre sujet que j'aime bien
c'est-à-dire les dessins animés donc on
va faire un retour dans le passé à
l'époque de l'âge d'or des dessins
animés he c'est-à-dire fin 80 début 90
d'ailleurs c'est probable qu'une partie
d'entre vous les plus jeunes en tout cas
ne connaissent pas les dessins animés
dont je vais vous parler donc ça sera
aussi l'occasion pour vous de découvrir
cette époque c'est toujours les
vacances il y avait deux choses qui ont
fait notre jeunesse c'est les jeux
vidéos et les dessins animés et même si
l'émission la plus connue de ma
génération reste le club doroté parce
que c'était la plus médiatisée il faut
quand même rendre hommage à la 5 qui a
emmené en France la majeure partie des
mangas japonais que nous on a
[Musique]
regardé en fait aux alentours des années
90 on retrouve plusieurs types de dessin
animés le style américain qui est plus
dans le genre on fait un dessin animé
pour vendre nos produits comme par
exemple GI Jo Musclor cosmocat
Transformers fortune ninja et ce
le style japonais qui faisait vraiment
de la production pas ch à la chane et le
style français qu' faut quand même le
reconnaître à l'époque on faisait
vraiment de super dessins
animés alors il y avait une chose qui
fait que les années 90 éta les années pH
c'est que toutes les séries presque
toutes les séries avaient des génériques
de fou en fait on se souvient de presque
tous les génériques même de séries qui
éta pas connu ou même de séries qu'on
aimait pas trop
faut dire qu'à l'époque en même temps on
se tapit toutes les séries les Juliette
je taime les Candy et compagnie juste
pour pas louper le
débutbz voilà moi ce que j'appelle
génriqueain du bon bien anné
[Musique]
90 gén
magme les Gén de bernardent pas
mal je conçois qu'un JEE quie maintenant
il doit bien rigoler quandme je dire la
chorégraphie pre derrière il a l'air de
s'emmerder bon après j'ai dit que
presque tous les génériques étaient bien
foutus parce que il y a quand même eu
des
[Musique]
carnages alors ça c'est du meurtre quoi
ça c'est horrible mais c'est c'est du
viol sauvage du générique original et
bon on avait quand même un paquet
générique assez bizarre
aussi j'aime la Gy et je m'entraîne
dans la vie
c'est quand même entre les dessins
animés aujourd'hui et ceux d'avant il y
a une autre très grosse différence celui
des thèmes abordés finalement les
dessins animés aujourd'hui ont des
thèmes assez superficiels tandis que
nous à l'époque no dessins animés éta
excellent mais ils avaient des thèmes
sérieux mais même des fois trop sérieux
en fait
souvenez-vous sans famille un enant qui
é enlevé puis vendu pour 40 francs par
son père il est ensuite racheté par un
homme Vitalis il se retrouve obligé de
travailler de se démerder tout seul il
va connaître le froid la faim la misère
en partant de Paris les animaux de Remy
meurent les uns après les autres en
premier son chien qui se fait bouffer
par les loups mais c'est bien le collier
de zbino
ça et
ça c'estes petits poils blancs ce sont
les poils de
dolci voilà je c'est pour les enfants
mon singe attrape une pneumonie et
Meur tu as été merveilleux mon petit
jeoli cœur merveilleux tu n'avais jamais
été aussi bien joli
cœur tout comme le général de la
pièce joli cœur était mort
d'épuisementou pistolet bidon d'essence
demander des allumettes
[Musique]
ensuite Vitalis le seul ami de Rémy
meurt de froid dans la neige quelques
instants après avoir rêvé de l'époque où
il était chanteur d'opéra Vitalis
s'endort dans son dernier sommeil voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on s'éclate c'est la mort
calme et paisible d'un homme remarquable
dont le dernier geste généreux a été de
sauver la vie de l'enfant qui estain
mais on dirait que même la voix off elle
au bord du suicide de quoi ce dessin
animé mais c'était vraiment le truc qui
te plombait une bonne matinée d'ailleurs
moi cette série je me souviens que je
l'évitais je veux dire ça me blasait
tellement que quand je tombais dessus je
zappais sur une autre
chaîne Princesse Sarah 8 ans sa mère est
morte son père est ruiné et mort aussi
accessoirement et du coup elle est
traitée comme une esclave par la gérante
de la pension où elle vit mademoiselle
Mangin d'ailleurs en fait cette femme
elle me rappelle ma prof de CP tu vois
double raison de pas l'aimer
on vient de m'apporter des nouvelles
concernant votre père nouvelles
concernant mon père oui on vient
de'annoneril c'est pour donc la
petiteaer sans
JB tout le qui mais
pasème
continzs bien
enfin mais rebelle-toi Sarah mais
sérieusement mais est-ce que je suis le
seul quand j'étais petit à avoir rêvé de
rentrer dans la télé pour la secouer
cette
fille
Sarah dis-moi un peu Sarah qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette façon de nettoyer mon
ardoise est toute pleine de
Cré Clémentine une enfant de 10 ans
handicapé moteur paraplégique cloué dans
son lit par un accident d'avion provoqué
par matmot un démon de flamme du coup
Clémentine s'échappe dans ses rêves là
où elle peut encore marcher cette série
avait un côté assez malsin déjà il y
avait un mort par épisode mais surtout
les morts où les accident n'était pas
ellipsé on te l'ai montré
essayez de vous imaginer enfant là c'est
absolument terrorisant ce passage on
sait pas si elle est morte là ou si elle
est en train de mourir sielle a l'agonie
oh mon Dieu où suis-je au secours je
tombe papa papa au secours papa je vais
mourir mais non tu écoutez ce que dit le
méchant des fois rejoindre dans mon re
de feu je te torturerai avec amour et ça
me donnera des idées en fait mais c'est
totalement sordide de dire des trucs
comme ça mais ça va pas mais elles vont
très bien mes jambes je ne les sens pas
du
tout je ne les sens plus papa je ne peux
plus bouger mes jambes je ne pourrais
plus marcher pas mais c'est horrible
mais mais franchement mais au
secours tu monre ça mais à des gosses au
fait Clémentine tu avais vraiment raison
pour la course on a gagné 288 kmh
nouveau record mondial tu te rends
compes ouais je me rends compte connard
je suis paralysé quoi sérieux je vois
pas ce qui pourrait lui arriver de pire
maintenant cette gamine
non non non
arrêtez attention cet extrait a
peut-être été sorti de son contexte je
veux dire si on se demande pourquoi la
France c'est le premier pays à consommer
des antidépresseurs faut pas chercher
plus loin des fois en fait même certains
génériques étaient flippants je sais pas
si vous vous rappeler du générique de il
était une fois l'homme ou à la fin les
derniers humains quittaient la terre
dans une fusée juste avant qu'elle
explose moi très sérieusement moi ce
générique cette fin de générique me
terrifiait et tant que je parle d'éité
d'une fois je dois dire que cette série
était d'ailleurs vraiment géniale
surtout l'ultra célèbre il était une
fois la vie que je conseille vraiment à
tous les gens qui connaissent pas d'
c'est marrant passage je sais pas si
vous avez remarqué mais les virus il
étaiit une fois la vie il ressemble à
Nicolas Sarkozi quoi alors c'est vrai
que la plupart des dessins animé tristes
étaient d'origine japonaise en fait la
plupart des dessins animés qu'on
regardait était ou japonais ou américain
du coup pour s'adapter au public le
passage à la VF était parfois un peu
fait à l'arracher on s'en apercevait pas
forcément à l'époque mais quand tu
regardes avec le recul tu te dis mais ou
là comment ils ont pu sortir ce genre de
truc déjà au niveau de la francisation
des noms et des lieux mais il y avait de
ces perles des fois vraiment prenez par
exemple une bonne vieille srie que
j'aime pas genre Lucille à mour rock and
roll pour ceux qui auraient oublié c'est
[Musique]
ça voil les bonnes vieilles coiffures
années 70 Mathias c'est son gros
chewing-gum collé dans les cheveux le
chat qui mangeait des crêpes
boulettes d'ailleurs le chat qui parlait
je sais pas ça choquait personne moi si
mon chat se me parler d'un coup je pense
que je flipperai quand même et avait
Benjamin ce gamin juste insupportable
tout le temps en train de chialer
mais il passe son temps à se mêler de la
vie sexuelle de son frère mais
mais il est gay ton frère il est gay tu
as pas compris je ve dire avec une
coiffure comme ça et des PES c'est
pourtant évident je sais pas
merde
ah mais c'est totalement cliché quoi
regardez l'arc-en-ciel dans la fontaine
le petit sert rose
oh mais pitié mais au secours mais à bat
tzl mais tu pleur elles sont belles tes
larmes ok je déconne ça ça y est pas
c'est moi qui l'ai rajouté cette série
non seulement les personnages étaient
insupportabl mais en plus pour la
version française tout se passe à Paris
nous sommes heureux d'être à ber avec
vous les mecs il font des concerts à ber
ils prennent le TGV ils passent par N et
alors qu'en réalité évidemment tout se
passe au Japon d'ailleurs ils ont bien
été emmerdés quand au dernier épisode la
mère de de Benjamin revient vraiment de
Paris dans la version originale et là
hop les mecs de la version française ils
ont retourné leur vestes et h d'un coup
tout se passent au Japon c'est genre on
a rien vu c'est la fête oui je regrette
de vous avoir menti jusqu'à maintenant
hein
ah une autre série que j'adore et bien
plus connue hein qui a eu des
doublages euh bizarres c'est Nicky
Larson je vous avais parlé rapidement de
Ken le survivant dans mon test sur Last
Battle là c'est un peu la même chose les
doubleurs des méchants dev s'éclater à
le travail parce que franchement même
les scènes qui sont sérieuses en VO
elles ont pris mais ont pris un air
complètement délirant en
français je veux dire prenez cette scène
par exemple en VO très sérieuse grosse
révélation
[Rires]
voilà la mêmef elle ne savait pas que
c'était moi qui avais fait assassiner
son
papa dis un peu quel effet ça fait
d'être recherché par la fille de son
ancien équipier ma explique-moi ça elle
veut venger son père j'espère que tu
apprécieras cet effort d'imagination de
ma part il en PER sa B
c'est pas la même chose hein les
méchants surtout d'une manière générale
en fait étaient totalement stupide en
français adieu mon petit
Momo je l'ai fait exprès de dire que
j'étais
mort lâche-moi lâche-moi en gros les
doubleurs adoucissaient volontairement
le manga pour en faire un dessin animé
pour enfants par exemple les love hôel
sont remplacés par des restaurants
végétariens les balles sont remplacés
par des boulettes enfin bref la série
est devenue culte en partie grâce à ça
bon après on aime ou on a'ime pas chacun
est juge he qu tu
dis par contre sur les versions
françaises il y a un truc que je
pardonne pas c'est Dragon Ball Z et les
traductions des attaques il y a pas de
mot pour décrire ce scandale donc en
français il y a pas
de à la place on a rayon
magique donc en français nous on n pas
de à la place nous on a attention
ou alors mais des fois carrément on te
mettait des kamameamea sans aucune
raison même les Chevaliers du Zodiaque
ils avaient leur même merde oui ensuite
plus rien il m'a envoyé une décharge
électronique décharge électronique
électronique mais ça veut rien dire
enfin d'ailleurs une autre grande
spécialité chez nous c'est le meublage
ça arrive des fois hein dans les dessins
animés que pendant quelques secondes les
personnages ne disent rien que c'est du
silence et ben chez nous non chez nous
les silences nous on les
[Musique]
meubles oh ben
oh oh ben oh
oh ben oh ben alors
oh
oh je suis enin le plus fort quand même
ils sont forts ces japonais Paris qu'ils
arrivent à te faire croire qu'un truc
totalement banal peut devenir un truc
complètement démentiel avec une ambiance
de fou je me souviendrai toujours de ce
dessin animé sur la cuisine qui
s'appelait le petit
[Musique]
chef voilà donc pour quelle raison il SP
les
[Musique]
auberg mais quand même l'exagération la
plus célèbre de notre enfant ça reste
Olive et
Tom entre les terrains qui fais 18 km de
longaris même pas à voir l'autre côté
les stades de 50000 personnes pour voir
deux équipes de Poussin jou qui étai
diffusé jusqu Antarctique Olivier qui il
avait trois codes cassés le tibia
fracturé 42 fières et pourtant il
continue à jouer c'était formidable pass
je ne sens plus rien les tirs de l'aigle
le tir du tigre que moi quand je quand
j'étais plus jeune et tout le monde qui
essaya de faire pareil au foot essayé de
faire comme Marc Landers après tu
mettais 5 minutes aller chercher le
ballon tu sais l'entraîneur de l'équipe
d'Olivier c'était Raymond Domec je veux
dire le mec il servait à rien et je
parle même pas de l'arbitre il y avait
des espèces d'attentat sur la pelouse
mais lui il ne sifflait jamais mais il
dort l'arbitre ou quoi même un aveugle
aurait sifflé ce couvrant et puis
évidment il avit fameux speaker dont on
se souvient tous et qui était là mais
dans toutes les séries en fait même dans
était
là après tout c'était classique des
dessins animés japonais d'exagérer mais
c'est vrai que Oliv Tom c'était quand
même le top du top niveau exagération il
a jamais rien eu de supérieur maintenant
c'était les années 90 maintenant tout ça
ça existe plus c'est dommage quelque
part et toi tu m'avais porté un D tu
m'avais dit c'était quoi c'est tennis
c'est un animé sur le tennis
đ
[Musique]
h ch ch ch
Tok en
mineur pas
dire ça fait peu
[Applaudissements]
allez donc au début du jeu vous
cheveux j'achète votre
[Musique]
filmz qui vous fait penser à un mauvais
film d'horreur c'est
la je reviens du futur et si
vous salut tout le monde alors cette
semaine pas envie de vous parler dessin
anim pendant des jours pour tester ce
truc
voilà allez donc allez
donc 5 minutes en train de pour de alle
donc pas problème mais il étai aussi
super
sérieux
souvenez-v je plus
[Musique]